[Music]
[Music]
we have an outbreak that has spread
around the world rapidly
through new models of transmission
about which we understand too little
and which meets the criteria in the
international health regulations
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it was
excruciating at times you know it um
i had intense flu-like symptoms so fever
chills sore throat
cough sweating through my sheets at
night
um and then you know the tell-tale skin
lesions which i had from the get-go but
more of them appeared throughout the
infection and towards the end i counted
more than 25 all over my body and they
just appeared everywhere
you know at worst on more sensitive skin
and more sensitive areas
[Music]
well it takes time for vaccines to work
and in this case it can take up to three
weeks i believe for this vaccine to take
full effect so being vaccinated does not
give you instant protection
the best way to avoid this infection is
to avoid been exposed to it and if you
are exposed to it to avoid being the
person that transmits that further to
somebody else
[Music]
all right health care is right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no one has come out and said
we are not giving this vaccine because
we don't think that the pain that gay
and by men are suffering
warrants a response from us no one has
said that but their actions say that
and we now
[Music]